né cherche cherche un truc cherche un
truc c'est bien au ban
oh c'est bien ma fille l'heure de la
récolte au coeur de la truffière un
travail à plusieurs avec pour seul guide
l'odeur ça sent fort ouais mais même
même moi quand je vais à gratter je sais
qu'à la truffe parce que la terre
vraiment elle elle prend elle prend la
rom donc eux ne peuvent pas se tromper
des fois il est sans tain m c'est
impressionnant
vounet et après quelques minutes
seulement nous donnera des chiens fait
ses preuves
ça c'est une belle truffe est de 70
grammes 80 g
c'est ce que les clients ils veulent de
la truffe noire du périgord oui mais
100% berry celle ci il faut savoir que
dans le département du cher et de l'ain
et se récolter 6 tonnes de truffes en
1870 1880
on est dans un terrain on a le terrain
le type même de sol capables de faire de
la truffe un sol argilo-calcaire de
l'humidité mais pas trop et puis de bons
chiens meilleur associé de l'homme
c'est comme le chasseur avec son chien
c'est exactement pareil houleux où le
gars qui cherche de la drogue pour que
je chéris sois gentil gourmand calme et
puis qu'il aime son maître de la
truffière à l'assiette il n'y a qu'un
pas aujourd'hui le mimosa au travail
avec le secret du cheddar de dijon qui
est déjà truffée de dents du coup ça
ramène encore plus de trucs tout
simplement une mayonnaise classique
vient ensuite l'ingrédient phare la
truffe et râper dans la base mimosas le
tout déposer sur le blanc d'oeuf
un exemple de recettes parmi d'autres
tous les pommes de terre crème leveaux
la volaille ce qui vient de blanche moi
je préfère je trouve que ça s'agace - la
truffe derniers détails de présentation
ici la truffe habits simplement l'oeuf
mimosas l'or noir du berry peut aussi
sublime et cette entrée dans sa version
gastronomique